is it really Westeros with our dragons
and Kings the upcoming Game of Thrones
spin off the Hedge Knights might just
give viewers an entirely new perspective
on life in the Seven Kingdoms
Game of Thrones had his fair share of
really really tall characters there's a
Hound who in the books is set to measure
in at six feet eight inches the actor
who played him Roy McCann is a close six
feet six inches then there was his
brother at the mountain that was played
by multiple actors but most notably by
Icelandic strongman have Thor beyonson
who is six feet nine inches well
certainly above average for a man the
bug saturation of the mountain was even
taller then there was briyan of Tarth
portrayed by the six foot three inch
Gwendolyn Christie Martin describes
Sarah as about six and a half feet and
two could forget Hodor the gentle giant
brought to life by six foot ten inch
actor Christian narian who held the door
for bran the Hedge Knight Will introduce
another person of preposterous stature
to the Game of Thrones extended Universe
the protagonist and point of view
character dunk is so tall that instead
of his family your place of birth his
defining characteristic becomes his name
sir Duncan the tallest reported to be
nearly seven fees by one account and
exactly six feet 11 inches by another
his size isn't just remarkable enough to
have been preserved in westeros's
history books it's also a comedic
contrast between dunk and his troubling
companion the diminutive egg very few
actors much dunk stats and Productions
usually use camera trickery and digital
effects to create such Illusions among
the fans suggestions for dunk are Henry
Cavill and George McKay both standing in
the vicinity of six feet in height
they're tall for movie stars but not for
Knights sensor Duncan's appearance is so
important to the story many readers are
hoping for a properly towering figure
which might mean casting someone
relatively unknown
of all of Martin's books a knight of the
seven Kingdom should be the easiest to
adapt The Game of Thrones had to fit
thousands of pages of story into seasons
one to five while House of the Dragon
uses only a tiny section of Fire and
Blood for its first 10 episodes both
thought to contend with dozens of
locations and hundreds of characters the
Hedge Knight in its accompanying graphic
novel on the other hand are less than
200 pages and feature one main setting
and a manageable number of central
players this means that's assuming the
show winners keep the book to a single
season the show ought to be able to
render the events of the novella at
about the same pace and with the same
amount of detail but adaptations
shouldn't be afraid to make changes and
improve the story for the new medium one
area where the TV show could do better
than the book is in its depiction of
dung's Mentor so our land of Penny tree
our land is an archetypical Game of
Thrones character like davo seaworth
he's an older nobleman and hard-working
Knight with the grizzled appearance and
demeanor good intentions and a slightly
mysterious backstory unfortunately we
never actually meet him in Martin's
writing and some fans want the series to
correct that well some folks on Reddit
have suggested starting the show with
sir Arlan other things that are Lan and
dung's relationship could be handled in
flashbacks family words and crests play
a vital part in the overall ascetic and
The Narrative of Game of Thrones there
are also many ancestral weapons like
swords and shields that mean a great
deal to various characters
in that sword
it's called heart pain
sir Duncan Shield serves as a cover of
some additions of a knight of the Seven
Kingdoms and this a major Easter egg
that supposedly connects dung to a
beloved major character down the line
though fans have yet to discover exactly
how in all likelihood viewers of the
Hedge Knights will get to see the origin
story behind their shield and this
design early in season one The Ultimate
reveal however probably won't come until
closer to the show's end when dunk comes
into possession of Sir arlan's
belongings he realizes that since he
isn't our land's son he cannot use the
penny tree symbol or colors a winged
Silver Chalice against a brown backdrop
the problem is that dunk isn't anybody's
son he was orphaned in his infancy and
knows nothing about his Heritage to
become a respected enough hedge Knight
to enter tournaments and find work he
basically has to invent an identity for
himself how plausible that identity is
boasts to dunk and a noble outside
observers is one of the main catalysts
of the action in a knight of the Seven
Kingdoms the way in which dunk comes by
his new purse personal coat of arms is
one of the book's more captivating
subplots the image and Elm Tree under a
shooting star is quite beautiful and
sure to Adorn tons of official merch
besides dragons Palace Intrigue violence
and Frozen zombies Game of Thrones is
also known for its steamy romances a
cursory glance through the history of
Westeros relationships were revealed
that most of them are complicated if not
utterly doomed from the start if the
Hedge Knight Hues closely to the text at
all dunk will have his very own fraud
subplot with a love interest and there's
one that some fans of the novella are
deeply invested in when he arrives at
the tournament at Ashford sir Duncan
makes the acquaintance of tansel a
dornish artist and Puppeteer who goes
from town to town with her Uncle as part
of a trooper performance dunk can't get
the statuesque tan cell whose nickname
is Too Tall out of his mind even those
who haven't read the book can probably
guess how things go for Duncan tan cell
based only on the premise that they both
lead somewhat transient Lifestyles and
Martin's tendency to rip lovers apart as
soon as he gets them together the fates
of iconic couples like Daenerys and
Drogo rub Stark and talissa John Jon
Snow and egress Jamie Lannister and
Brienne isande and gray worm and Jon
Snow and Daenerys still pull up the
heartstrings of many viewers but that's
not the point the point is Martin's best
pairings crackle with tension
particularly before they get together
dunk doesn't have tyrions we're toward
Jamie's charm but he's as much a lover
as he is a fighter and the Hedge Knight
chaletsis chivalrous lead for hard
enough for Tan cell that he has
something to think about as he wanders
Westeros in later seasons there's an
ancient saying about the Targaryen
Dynasty they say every time a Targaryen
is Born the gods toss a coin and the
world holds its breath
that's his size of this allegorio coin
are greatness and Madness Duncan
audiences will come into contact with a
whole new generation of targaryens in
the night of the Seven Kingdoms and that
coin flip wisdom will hold up that's
caught around the time of Sir Duncan or
Prince maker and Prince Baylor
breakspeare as well as make our sons the
princess Daron Aryan aemon and aegon
thereon goes down in history as dare run
the drunken he's plagued by prophetic
dreams and self-medicates with drink and
women to ease his mind he's no Peach but
his fellow Prince Arion is much worse
Ariana who calls himself bright flame
will probably function as a main
antagonist in the Hedge Knight as
targaryens go he doesn't inflict the
worst or the most damage though he's
still completely vile and cruel he's in
the running for the most mad however
this vicious Prince has really into his
family's history with Dragons so much so
that he eventually believes himself to
be one erion decorates his clothing to
approximate the look of a dragon and
Dabble in dark magic to compare his
character to another fantasy series is
like a combination of gildroid Lockhart
crossed with Voldemort from Harry Potter
he's the antithesis of dunk whose kind
and self-deprecating if HBO Maxes the
Hedge Knight gets survivalry rice the
series should be a hit
and neither the Seven Kingdoms takes
place almost exactly in between House of
the dragon and Game of Thrones dragons
existed during those series but sadly
their extinct in Duncan egg's age or
casual viewers still tune in for a
dragonless fantasy show some fans don't
think it will be a problem thanks to
another massive spectacle tournaments
while doors and jousting might not sound
especially enticing to fans used to
seeing enormous monsters on screen
without CGI dragons taking a bite out of
production budgets that money can go
toward making season 1's tournaments
extra Grand of course there have been
several tournaments in series set in
Westeros already on Game of Thrones
Robert Joffrey and Rani Baratheon all
hold tournaments for its parts house of
the Dragons Premiere episode showcases
for saris Targaryen tournament intended
to celebrate the birth of his and Emma's
some with one since several prominent
tales and a knight of the Seven Kingdoms
take place at tawny's this should mean
they'll take center stage in the
television adaptation if done correctly
instead of massages of jousting and soul
play the Hedge Knight or to show the
Tony in full and allow the audience to
get to know and care about each entrant
Westeros isn't exactly an egalitarian
society there's a ruling class and a
working class and there are mistakably
distinct from each other though being of
noble birth comes with its challenges
it's no picnic being a servant at King's
Landing let alone a peasants on the
streets of flea bottom one of the few
contacts in which the landed gentry and
the common folk mix Live Theater Mama's
troops often perform lewd versions of
Royal history in the world of Thrones
for the rich and the poor alike for
example teenage rhaenyra gets a taste of
local politics when her Uncle Damon
takes her on a late night field trip to
witness a roast of her own family as
previously mentioned tansel is a member
of a troop of puppeteers that assembled
to entertain the crowds gathered for the
Tony that true but somewhat turns out to
be quite a controversial and
consequential show with marionettes like
wooden dragons while it upsets
characters in world the show's potential
audience in our world to get excited to
see them acted out the creators of Game
of Thrones and House of the Dragon have
done an exemplary job already with these
types of stories within stories tan
sales puppet show is yet another chance
for the casting crew of The Hedge Knight
to get creative putting their own spin
on a franchise tradition
just as the citizens of Westeros don't
enjoy income equality they also can't
depend on a very fair legal system for
those suspected of a crime in Martin's
world the choices often between corporal
punishment or trial by combat I demand a
trial by combat Game of Thrones fans
have been present for some Marquee
trials by combat mostly involving Tyrion
Lannister Braun fights on his behalf the
first time Oberon Martell II these
scenes are some of the highlights of the
whole series without giving too much
away dung finds himself in a similar
position at some point during the events
of a knight of the Seven Kingdoms
fortunately he is more than capable of
defending himself unfortunately his
adversary demands a trial by seven in
which both the accuser and the accused
must assemble a team of seven to square
off in what amounts to a mega door this
is easier said than done for dunk who
isn't Highborn and doesn't have a
Lannister's money or connections the
trial by 7 is the climax of The Hedge
Knight and fans on Twitter are losing
their minds above possibility of seeing
it in live action it will be the first
time book readers will see a trial by 7
on screen with each night of battling
with his choice of fighting style and
weapon and they will put a number of the
show's main characters in a life or
death situation
if all goes well the Hedge Knight could
comprise the first of at least three
seasons of a knight of the Seven
Kingdoms while there are some
recognizable tie-ins to the author's
overwriting story in part one most of
the stuff fans are really waiting to see
won't happen until much later in dung's
life sir Duncan plays a pivotal role in
the blackfyre rebellions he's rumored to
have fathered at least one child and is
sought to be related to at least one
favorite Game of Thrones character he
even crosses paths with the likes of A
Song of Ice and Fire veterans Walter
Fray barrist and selmy and maester aemon
though dung's tale is relatively modest
in scope and length it offers a fresh
perspective and to keep pieces of
Martin's law not to mention sir Duncan
the tool becomes a legendary Knight in
his own regard we don't know if a knight
to the Seven Kingdoms will stop where
the novellas do as of now or if Martin
and Max will explore Westeros through
dunk's eyes beyond the mystery night but
we can hope that if the Hedge Knight is
successful this series and other
spin-offs could eventually give fans
live-action adaptations of more of their
favorite book moments